[Musique]
jusqu'au 17 septembre plongée dans les
sous-sols du château de maisons à
Maisons-Laffitte et venez découvrir la
nouvelle exposition magie baroque
[Musique]
travers des décors merveilleux partez à
la rencontre de deux grandes magiciennes
de la Renaissance Altina et armid il y a
d'abord alchina qui est une création
d'un auteur de la Renaissance qui
s'appelait larriost et qui à travers le
Roland Furieux qu'un immense roman
chevaleresque a inventé cette figure
d'une magicienne qui vit sur une île
lointaine et qui va piéger des
chevaliers dans son jardin et son palais
d'illusion et va tomber amoureuse de
l'un d'eux qui sera relent la deuxième
magicienne évoquée dans cette exposition
est Armide une figure inventée par le
poète le Tasse à travers son roman La
Jérusalem délivrée c'est de femmes ont
inspiré de nombreuses créations
artistiques au 16e et 17e siècle jusqu'à
Louis XIV qui a souhaité représenter
alfina dans une grande pièce théâtrale
pour inaugurer son château à Versailles
[Musique]
nous avons par ailleurs dans le tout au
long de l'exposition travailler avec
deux danseurs périnalisa et
Jean-Baptiste plumeau et ces deux
personnages représentent à la fois le
chevalier en prisonnier et la magicienne
donc nous apportons aussi un peu
d'humanité dans ces décors donc on suit
l'histoire en quelque sorte on emmène le
visiteurs à travers l'île enchantée tout
d'abord une création de Laetitia Miral
et on terminera par un tableau qui est
celui de la métamorphose ou le chevalier
qui a été emprisonné figé en quelque
sorte dans cette ILLUSION va se libérer
bien entendu de ces charmes filtres
d'amour jardin enchanté banquier les
œuvres prennent vie grâce aux ambiances
sonores et visuelles mises en place
attention à ne pas vous faire ensorceler
ou envoûté
[Musique]